[Music]
to win this election I think it would
mean the world to across the country in
the Congress there have been roughly
12,000 people elected to 1789 and of
that number about 300 Native Americans
and yet never a woman
why you and why now why me and why now
well why not me why not now you just
remember the day that she was like I'm
gonna run for Congress and I was like
that sounds like something you would do
you know like she's always just been
like I'm gonna do this and when she says
she's gonna do something she gets it
done
she saw that people weren't getting out
to vote she saw that there are
underrepresented communities and she
walked into an office one day and
volunteered her time I wanted people to
have a voice in our politics I did it
because I felt that that's how I could
benefit my community hi Laurie well the
night of the primary she was a lot less
emotional than all the rest of us were
she was not surprised I don't think it
just seemed like oK we've crossed one
hurdle and now we have another one
directly in front of us right without
any time like not a second to spare it
was like all of a sudden a light went on
she's been on a roll ever since
[Applause]
you have power loosely hi everyone I'm
Dan Sullivan
the last day to register to vote I'm so
proud of the race that we've run and I
couldn't have done any of it without you
this year
women are breaking campaign records
across the board Native women are a part
of that
well it's not how it looks at two of the
candidates Deb Holland in New Mexico and
Charisse David's in Kansas when Deb won
the primary it suddenly got national
attention and showed how overdue that is
how this should be a routine story in
2018 rather than being the first time
ever
she talks about it in a way that what I
want to do is give Native Americans a
seat at the table Indian country will
see how important it is to have full
representation to show that Americans
need to include first Americans as part
of the national discourse I think it
would mean that we're taking another
step closer to equality to be fierce
means to me that you're just speaking
out that you're giving voice to folks
who haven't had a voice in our politics
not everything always has to be about
what holds high and how many votes
you're going to win off that issue I
think it should be an issue that that
you truly care about and that's why
you're running for office one of the
issues I think she can probably make a
big difference on is climate change I
think that's one where the Native
communities have a stake almost
immediately
[Music]
I went to Standing Rock in September of
2016 because I felt like I needed to
stand with the water protectors Native
Americans in that movement join forces
to speak up for the environment Standing
Rock was one of those moments that
whether or not they were successful
blocking the pipeline that idea that you
can use this newfound authority to do
things was something that I think was
infectious family is so important to her
just because you decide to run for
office it doesn't mean that you can
neglect all of your other obligation I'm
still a mother to my daughter soma what
she has said to me as I read like I
raised you as a fob Lohmann that means
so much to me her family history is so
rich in tradition I mean both military
and railroad I am a thirty fifth
generation New Mexican my mother in
particular and my grandmother they were
two the hardest working women I've ever
known my grandmother she used to clean
diesel train engines with a bucket of
kerosene and a brush my mom was a
25-year federal employee she worked in
Indian education I inherited their work
ethic watching her with that work ethic
when it came to any sort of like
community event that needed to happen
that really stuck with me
probably the greatest difference between
say Western philosophy and native
philosophy is the role of the individual
versus the role of a community
individualism only takes you so far if
the Pueblo people had had that
individual success mentality I just
don't think we would have survived as a
people Deb has like many other women in
history just paved the way for us a
little bit not only for Native American
women but women of color and women in
general for the first time a young girl
living at laguna pueblo could say i can
grow up to be president that has not
been possible because they never saw
anybody that looked like them and i
think that is more important than any
single election
[Music]
I'm just really proud of cuz that's what
she does she says she's gonna do
something and she does whatever it takes
to get it done we didn't realize all the
ramifications she was just looking to be
the congresswoman from District one in
New Mexico and it's become a much much
bigger thing than that I think she's
just somebody who's worked awfully hard
for a long time without credit or glory
and being in Congress for her is not an
end goal it's part of what she can do to
change the world
I'm not surprised by anything that she's
done she's doing it she's killing it
live
hi everyone I'm Deb Pollock today is
election day what are you waiting for
let's get out and vote
extremely hard we've done our messaging
we have a strong field program knocking
on thousands and thousands of doors and
calling thousands and thousands of
voters and in the end there's nothing
you can do you just have to sit back and
wait like everyone else for the results
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you all so much I think the day
she takes the oath of office a lot of
people in Indian country will basically
have chills really hard it's really
important to reclaim the narrative and
so I think in that sense job is bringing
back an older story this country cannot
pretend that this history didn't exist
and it can't be what it wants to be
without
[Music]